[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Jean-François Copé merci d'être avec
nous les républicains de m en etarne on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par Christel
Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
Christ bonjour bonjour Jean-François COP
bonjour on commence par ce qui s'est
passé cette jean-fançois Copé cet accord
qui a donc été trouvé sur une libération
de 50 Otages aux mains du Hamas en
échange d'une trêve de 4 jours dans la
bande de Gaza qui est le gagnant de cet
accord selon vous oh écoutez là je crois
parler de gagnant alors qu'on évoque une
tragédie aussi atroce n'a absolument
aucun sens je pense surtout que cette
intervention militaire d'Israël dans
Gaza a permis d'inverser le rapport de
force vis-à-vis du Hamas et de faire en
sorte que on puisse un peu progresser
dans la possibilité de sauver la vie
d'un certain nombre d'otagees et c'est
évidemment de ce point de vue une bonne
nouvelle euh la situation est absolument
dramatique tout cela est partie de cette
atrocité du du 7 octobre je sais que au
Sénat ont été projeté hier des images de
ce crime d'une barbarie
effroyable qui confirme si besoin en
était que le Hamas est bien une
organisation terroriste vous seriez allé
juste à la projection si vous avez étiez
pas si vous aviez été sénateur ah ben
bien sûr bien sûr mais pour autant c'est
pas pour moi qu'elle est utile cette
projection euh je pense que les
Israéliens ont bien fait en réalité de
de montrer ces images parce que vous le
savez il y avait un espèce de de
mouvement révisionniste pour employer un
terme à dessin c'est-à-dire celui qui a
conduit un certain nombre de de gens à à
essayer de nier la réalité de de la Choa
pendant la la suite de la 2uxème guerre
mondiale il y avait déjà des gens qui
expliquaient que tout ça n'était pas
vrai et donc ces images permettent de
montrer l'intensité de cette barbarie
qui a eu lieu le 7 octobre et donc pour
cela les images étaient importantes et
je pense en particulier vis-à-vis de
l'extrême gauche française dont un
certain nombre de membres a commencé par
leur inspirateur
Mélenchon ont déshonoré la France
justement pour parler le propos pour
parler de ce qui se passe en France il y
a plus de 1700 actes antisémites qui ont
été recensés sur le territoire depuis le
7 octobre comment on lutte contre cette
résurgence après la marche qui a eu lieu
Gérard Larché disait espérer une dém
benah écoutez d'abord cette marche elle
a montré par son ampleur par la
mobilisation euh de des Français qui ont
participé euh que fondamentalement il y
avait un refus mais vicéral en France de
de l'antisémitisme ça veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas des antisémites mais ça
veut dire que fondamentalement parce que
l'histoire n'est pas une page blanche
parce qu'il y a eu la Seconde Guerre
mondiale parce qu'il y a eu l'affaire
drefus parce qu'il y a eu toute une
série d'éléments qui ont structuré
l'histoire de la République française
euh et bien la France se refuse en
réalité euh à à ce que l'antisémitisme
perdure après euh moi j'ai beaucoup
regretté évidemment comme j'imagine
beaucoup de Français qu'Emmanuel Macron
ne s'y soit pas rendu je pense que c'est
une faute politique et morale car ne pas
se rendre à cette manifestation c'est
donné à penser qu'il puisse se trouver
au milieu entre ceux qui sont
antisémites et ceux qui ne le sont pas
alors que ça n'est pas une opinion ça
doit être un des piliers de la
République la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme ça ne doit pas être
discutable donc euh pourquo la lettre
qu'il a faite aux Français c'est pas
suffisant enfin écoutez moi je pense que
sur ces sujets-là il y a des moment fort
j'ai tous les présidents de la
République depuis 1945 d'ailleurs hein
ont tous tous systématiquement montrer
qu'il ne pouvait pas y avoir de débat
sur ce sujet euh c'est ce qui fait la
différence avec avant la la la deuxè
guerre mond l'Union et ne pas diviser
mais ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
donc il considère que il faut respecter
autant les antisémites que ceux qui ne
le sont pas c'est c'est pas c'est c'est
ce qui fait la différence entre ce qui
relève d'un débat d'opinion on peut
avoir un débat par exemple sur la
politique menée par Israël c'est un
débat mais en revanche sur des choses
aussi essentielles que l'antisémitisme
que le
racisme il faut être extraordinairement
clair ça n'est pas une opinion parce que
nous avons eu en Europe la Seconde
Guerre mondiale qui est le résultat
d'idéologies raciste qui ont conduit à
des millions de morts et dans des
conditions tros vous comprenez et ça
c'est un sujet sur lequel je considère
que les présidents de la République
française encore une fois au regarde de
l'histoire des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres ne peuvent pas donner le
sentiment de la moindre ambigué François
mitteran a manifesté à Carpentra vous le
savez Jacques Chirac a fait le discours
du Vald donc sur ces sujets nous devons
être extrêmement clair ça n'est pas une
opinion voilà donc ensuite cette
initiative prise par Gérard Larché et
yel brun Pivet était effectivement
excellente il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de
doute là-dessus
le gouvernement de ce point de vue
d'ailleurs réagit fort bien et moi je
voudrais saluer Gérald armanin qui est
extrêmement clair sur la détermination
du gouvernement et du ministère de
l'intérieur après il faut bien dire que
malheureusement le nombre de sanction
enfin d'interpellation est extrêmement
faible hélas par rapport à ces actes
puisque c'est vraiment quelques dizaines
seulement par rapport au 1000 et
quelques plus le dernier chiffre voilà
1700 actes antisémit relevés on va
parler de du Congrès des mèes Christelle
oui qui s'est ouvert hier on ressent
beaucoup de l'assitude chez les édiles
comme chaque année finalement vous vous
êtes mère de M depuis presque 18 ans ah
beaucoup plus que ça beaucoup plus que
ça depuis 1995 en effet excusez-moi et
justement est-ce que vous vous comprenez
cette lassitude est-ce que vous sentez
là de d'être mère de non non non non non
moi je suis passionné par ce mandat et
j'ai si je le suis c'est parce que que
et j'ai même fait le choix de renoncer à
cause de cette stupidité d'interdiction
pour les maires d'être députés mais j'ai
renoncé donc à être parlementaire
revenir oui je vais vous en dire un mot
dans un instant mais parce que en fait
les maires c'est ceux qui tiennent la
République au
quotidien c'est c'est c'est parce que
nous sommes en fonction que nous
apportons les réponses publiques
d'intérêt général quotidienne à nos
administrés que nous transformons nos
villes moi je peux enorter tmoignage
dire un mot nous avions des quartiers
qui étaient des véritables ghetto 20
tours que nous avons démoli nous avons
mis à la place des immeubles de quatre
étages on a sécurisé les quartiers on a
plus la même ville et donc en réalité
cette approche là change
considérablement les choses la
difficulté des maires aujourd'hui
malheureusement de congrès en congrès on
dit tout le temps la même chose he parce
qu'il y a pas on peut reprendre les
mêmes discours que l'année dernière et
que l'année d'avant c'est que les maires
sont de plus en plus enserré dans des
contraintes normatives leur
vulnérabilité pénale est est pire
d'année en année
leur rémunération est extrêmement faible
alors qu'ils y consacrent 7 jours sur 7
et et le tout dans une ambiance où
finalement ils ont le sentiment que les
autorités de l'État ne sont pas là pour
les protéger pour les soutenir pour les
encourager mais pour les finalement pour
pour plutôt leur mettre des bâtons dans
les roues alors oui alors c'est pas vrai
au quotidien parce qu'en même temps la
relation avec les préfets elle est très
bonne en fait au quotidien il nous aide
les services de l'État moi j'ai j'ai une
haute idée du service de l'État donc je
vois bien cela au quotidien ce que je
regrette c'est que au niveau national le
discours politique ne soit pas celui-là
vous savez que que que le Président de
la République soit pas au Congrès des
maire euh c'est pas bien en fait parce
que c'est vous ressentez de quelle
manière ça qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
ça envoie comme signal écoutez le signal
que ça envoie c'est que finalement bah à
Paris finalement on peut faire sans eux
quoi et et c'est pas bien parce que on
passe sa vie à plenicher sur le fait
qu'il y a une déconnexion entre Paris et
les régions et puis on interdit au maire
de de d'être à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est-à-dire là où se fait la loi c'est
c'est une
absurdité monsieur Macron aurait pu
revenir dessus il l'a jamais voulu le
faire parce qu'au fond de lui c'est pas
son histoire il a jamais été maire vous
le savez il est il est il a été élu dans
des conditions absolument inouies et
tant mieux c'est c'est c'est beau les
destins mais mais on en fait quelque
chose vous voyez ce que je veux dire
quand on est élu on se dit bon ben il
faut que je je compense quand même en
ayant autour de moi des gens qui vont me
me donner cette expérience que je n'ai
pas et et on n pas eu ça on a eu plutôt
un péché d'orgueil durant après la crise
des gilets jaunes durant les grands
débats il a semblé retisser le lien avec
les maires qu'il n'avait pas en effet au
début de son mandat euh ça a été une
parenthèse mais le problème si vous
voulez c'est que il a de temps en temps
ce type de d'intuition géniale en
communication c'était malin le grand
débat et beaucoup de mères y ont cru
comme d'ailleurs beaucoup de
responsables politiques ont cru au truc
de Saint-Denis au mois d'août là mais le
problème c'est que ça n'est jamais suivi
des faits vous comprenez et que ça n'est
pas suivi des fait alors évidemment les
maires le rappellent en lui disant mais
quand même vous nous aviez promis et là
il dit mais les maires n'ont qu'à se
taire il n'ont rien à dire regardez
cette hisire histoire de de d'impôt il a
supprimé au maire la taxe d'habitation
alors cela dit soyons juste Sarkozy
avait supprimé la taxe professionnelle
enfin supprimé des entreprise continue
de la payer mais c'est plus au bénéfice
des des collectivités locales ce qui est
idiot parce qu'en réalité en faisant ça
on enlève ce qui permet au maire de
gérer leur commune vous imaginez mais du
coup est-ce qu'il faut créer un nouvel
impôt local je pense que d'une manière
il faudra substituer cette impôt au aux
subventions parce queévidemment le
compte n'y est jamais l'état dit oui je
vous inquiétez pas je vous compense la
tax d'habitation je vous supprime la
première année puis après ilsarrêtent
ils font moins chaque jour un peu moins
bah oui c'est très dur vous comprenez on
a des déficits bah oui mais vous avez
des déficit parce que vous avez dépensé
n'importe comment alors évidemment à ce
moment-là vous avez toujours le discours
c'est les collectivités locales qui
gèent mal mais c'est faux collectivités
locales gèent plutôt bien les finances
publiques parce que vous souitez la
création d'un nouvel impôt local ou
pasbat NOTAM un impôt de résidence je
pense que il faut absolument qu'il y ait
une maîtrise fiscale pour les
collectivités locales parce estce qu'une
décentralisation réussie ça se mesure
pas au transfert de de compétences ça se
mesure au à l'autonomie fiscale moins
vous avez d'autonomie fiscale moins vous
êtes en réalité autonome bah évidemment
si vous dépendez des dotations de l'État
donc on va dire vous vous on a plus
envie de vous donner d'argent et donc on
étrangle les maires et donc beaucoup
d'entre eux aujourd'hui sont dans cette
situation alors si vous ajoutez à ça la
solitude du maire quand même parce que
bah c'est quand même vous qui décidez
avec votre équipe municipale dans des
conditions qui sont pas très simples bah
tout ça ça donne un sentiment d'abandon
voilà et c'est très mal parce que déjà
que les députés servent plus à rien je
le dis gentiment mais enfin c'est la
vérité ils sont sympa mais parce que
parce qu'en réalité ils n'ont plus de
contact avec la réalité locale personne
va les voir quand on va voir un élu on
est un habitantir élu parceon a quel
chose mais non mais parce qu'on a
quelque chose à lui demander on va lui
parler de son problème de logement de
son problème d'emploi de son problème de
de violence conjugale de son problème de
quartier et c'est à ce moment-là que le
et on va voir qui on va voir le maire
c'est le maire qui va résoudre le
problème le député ou rien le député je
vais écrire au maire de votre commune
voilà pour voir s'il peut vous aider
donc on très vite les gens vont plus
voir les députés qu'est-ce qui faisait
la force de la République c'était que
quand vous aviez des députés ou des
sénateurs qui étaient Mair en même temps
ils incarnaient un territoire leur
paroles étaient respectés entendu
c'était des piliers régionaux de la
République ce qu'on appelle pour les
discrédités des barons des féodaux je ne
sais quoi mais en réité non c'était
quelque part des piliers des gens qui
incarnaient solidement quel seul mais
ils sont mais c'est c'est pas un peu
c'est pas de leur faute mais à force de
dire le Nouveau Monde tout ce qui était
avant était nul vous allez voir ce que
vous allez voir bah ouais on voit c'est
comme quand Richard Berry dit à Patrick
Bruel dans l'union sacrée tu as voulu
voir taas vue on a vu ça ça on a vu
objectivement on a vu on a vu quoi on a
vu des parlementaires sympa c'est pas le
sujet ils ont des idées ils sont ils ont
leur histoire mais en fait personne va
les voir
personne et d'ailleurs ça se traduit par
exemple par le fait que aujourd'hui vous
avez quasiment pas pas de députés qui
ont émergé en terme de personnalité on
vous dit pas il y a un orateur
incroyable qui a porté sauf l'extrême
gauche composé de gens qui sont
uniquement là pour faire de l'agitation
de la déstabilisation ce qui pour dans
votre métier à vous est génial ça vous
permet de faire du truc mais c'est pas
ça la République vous voyez et ce
discrédit du débat public fait que
beaucoup de gens ne veulent plus faire
de politique en réalité et c'est ça qui
ne va pas parce que ce métier qui était
d'une noblesse absolue il y a encore
quelques années et qu'on avait envie de
s'engager pour notre pays aujourd'hui il
rend les gens tellement vulnérable qu'il
affaiblit la République à un moment où
les défis géopolitiques on en a parlé
tout à l'heure et nationaux sont
considérables et nous n'avons plus la
classe politique pour tenir face à cela
et c'est ça qui est grave est-ce qu'il
faut augmenter les indemnités des mes
c'est un des
élément regardez ce qu'il en est de
leurs indemnités aujourd'hui c'est
beaucoup trop faible donc ça les rend
terriblement là aussi vulnérable ils ne
peuvent pas tenir longtemps pour des tas
de raisons mais ça doit faire partie
d'un tout et puis puis il faut arrêter
de le faire en mégotant c'est on dit oui
on va le faire mais pas complètement et
puis que vont penser les autres Français
bah les autres Français d'abord enfin je
pense que fondamentalement ils
respectent leur mère donc il y a
globalement les Français trouvent que
les élus sont trop payés même B oui mais
mais mais personne n'en parle vraiment
de manière transparente et puis je vais
vous dire ce que je pense derrière tout
cela le président de la République qui
veut vraiment le faire il l'assumera
devant les Français mais je l'assume
c'est mon rôle de président de la
République de vous dire vos élus doivent
être bien rémunérés et je je peux
comment ça vous choque que tout doit
être gratuit mais moi je l'assume parce
que je sais ce que ça veut dire d'être m
et au fond de vous vous le savez aussi
vous voyez ce que je veux dire quelque
part ce qui me gêne terriblement c'est
que on est prisonnier de cette espèce de
de démagogie de l'immédiateté et et qui
coûte si cher à l'efficacité publique
Chistelle on parle de la lo immigration
oui qui va arriver très prochainement en
discussion à l'Assemblée et qui vient
d'être voté au Sénat dans une version
plutôt durcie qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de cette version je l'ai écrit je l'ai
écrit dans mon éditoriel de L'Express
moi je pense beaucoup de de de de bien
de cet accord il est pas parfait mais je
pense du bien parce que c'est un accord
et que moi je veux cette loi comme tous
les Français qui en ont assez de ces
tergiversations ça fait 3 ans qu'on
parle de cette loi mais enfin c'est on
attend combien de temps pour adresser un
message au filière d'immigration
mafieuse en fait c'est quand même ça le
sujet en moi j'ai encore eu dans ma
permanence un mot quelqu'un qui est venu
me demander une régularisation je
demandé de me raconter son histoire bah
oui il est passé par un bateau il était
de Tunisie alors c'est un
monsieur respectable il a envie de
réussir voilà on va voir ce qu'on va
faire mais enfin pour un qui a envie de
s'en sortir combien en réalité sont dans
des situations depérance de désespérance
qui les rend parfois dangereux pour
eux-mêmes et pour les autres quand même
donc faut voir un peu tout ça alors je
je je suis pas du tout fan je m'empresse
de vous le dire de cette filière de de
régularisation qu'on est en train de
mettre en place avec ce qu'on appelle
publiquement les métiers en T est en
gros les métiers que no compatriotes
français voudrai pas faire bon donc je
pense que en réalité ce sujet est un peu
délirant parce que enfin quand
même on a quand même un taux de chômage
qui n'est pas tombé à zéro j'ai vu même
que les chômage était un peu remonté
donc quand même je dis mais certains
patrons dans certains secteurs le
demandent oui d'accord certains patrons
le demandent mais ça prouve bien qu'il y
a quelque chose qui marche pas en France
quand même parce que d'un côté donc on
indemnise des gens qui sont au chômage
et de l'autre on a des filières en
tension parce qu'on trouve pas à
embaucher donc je dis juste il y a un
problème c'est un problème qui relève
d'ailleurs du min du travail pas du
ministère de l'Intérieur comment on le
résout ce problème bah bah on le résout
par exemple en regardant un peu ce qui
conduit des gens à refuser un travail
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est c'est
enfin je pense c'est un sujet quand même
on peut le poser ça veut dire une
nouvelle réforme de l'assurance chômage
ah oui enfin écoutez quand même enfin je
veux dire il il y a un truc qui va pas
il y a des gens qui cherchent du travail
puis des gens qui ont des indemnités au
chômage enfin on sait tout ça depuis des
années on a le système le plus généreux
au monde en matière sociale enfin quand
même des droit et dev plôt écoutez il
faudrait y passer un peu plus de temps
on va pas traiter la réforme de
l'assurance maladie de l'assurance
chômage en 5 minutes mais même pas en 2
minutes mais ce que je veux vous dire en
tout cas c'est qu'il y a une incohérence
complète je pense que c'était deux
volets différents c'est ce qu'on fait
paye avec cette histoire du en même
temps faut faire plaisir à la gauche à
la droitein tout ça est intenable on le
sait tous en plus il y a pas de majorité
absolue mais pour autant l'accord issu
du Sénat est un accord qui permet
d'avoir cette loi et donc j'ai plutôt
tendance à vous dire que si jamais ça
pouvait passer bah ce serait bien pour
la France voilà c'est un message que
vous lancez au députés LR votez la
version du Sénat parce qu'ils sont pas
tous sur cette ligne au R pas par ex il
y en a très peu qui sont sur cette donc
ça m'inquiète un peu mais qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je vous dise je pense
que c'est l'intérêt de la France voilà
vous craignez que le texte ressorte de
la commission des lois avec à
nouveau la suppression de l'article qui
supprime la me donc un rétablissement de
la me et un article 3 qui soit beaucoup
plus souple bah écoutez c'est c'est tout
ce qu'on veut pas quoi en fait voilà
c'est-à-dire que l'idée c'est que moi je
pense que laame non mais l'aide médicale
d'ta il faut il faut il faut une bonne
fois pour toutes tirer des conséquences
de tous ces abus c'est considérable
c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros l'aide
médicale d'État n'a aucun sens autant ça
a du sens de traiter les urgences autant
de de de de faire que des des
étrangersres situation irrégulière est
une totale gratuité des soins alors que
ceux qui sont en situation régulière
comme nos compatriotes payent des
franchises c'est délirant délirant donc
là c'est une partie de la majorité vous
pointez du doigt parce que c'est cette
partie de la majorité qui dit je nous ne
voterons pas le texte si on ne rétablit
pas la me et si on rétablit ça fait
malheureusement des années et des années
que c'est comme ça que nous ne sommes
pas capables d'avoir une Assemblée
nationale en phase avec à la fois le bon
sens et les attentes du pays voilà mais
c'est que la majorité ou c'est aussi
chez vous chez oui les deux les deux
vous m'avez demandé la majorité je vous
répond sur la majorité mais je vous dis
les deux bien sûr mais c'est le le je
pense que nos amis députés LR doivent
intégrer quand même que cette loi elle
est nécessaire on peut pas tout toute la
journée dire que ça ne va pas qu'il faut
une politique ferme en matière
d'immigration et de l'autre quand on a
des mesures qui aident à régler un
certain nombre de problèmes ne pas la
voter ça n'a aucun sens aucun la
majorité veut faire voter cette loi 1493
quitte à faire durer les débats jusqu'à
mi-janvier fin
janvier est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un risque
politique à occuper l'espace médiatique
on va dire avec ces discussions là
qu'est-ce que il y a un PCH originel
dans ce mandat qu'on veut pas qu'on fait
semblant ne pas voir il y a pas de
majorité absolue la 5e République elle
fonctionne sur la majorité absolue
chaque constitution je peux le dire ici
on est la chaîne Sénat chaque
constitution fonctionne sur une règle la
4e République c'était des coalitions
ponctuelles par loi bon c un désordre
infini il y av pas de président de la
République efficace et cetera depuis la
5e République vous avez un exécutif
efficace avec un président de la
République qui a des pouvoirs à la
condition qu'il est la majorité absolue
monsieur Macron comme d'ailleurs et
l'air ont refusé de se parler au
lendemain des législatives où les franç
n'ont pas voulu de majorité absolue en
l'état parce qu'ils voulit que la
politique soit plus à droite bon au lieu
de l'entendre personne ne l'entendu
c'estàdire que Monsieur Macron n'a
surtout pas voulu l'entendre il est le
maître des horloges je pensais que
c'était Dieu pour ceux qui y croient
mais non c'est lui et de l'autre les LR
je me souviens j'ai fait un bureau
politique on a fait le tour de la table
j'ai défendu cette idée en disant mais
les amis enfin vous vous rendez compte
la chance qu'on peut avoir de enfin
participer au gouvernement du pays en
faisant une coalition intelligente sur
les textes que nous définissions sur un
programme et tous autour de la mais tous
tous les les chapeaux à plume que je
connais j'aime bien par ailleurs les
vquier les berdard non non on ne veut
pas non non non non on veut pas B génial
donc la France est bloqué cause de çaur
d'Emmanuel Macron ça a été de ne pas
nommer un Premier ministre issu desir je
pense que l'erreur d'Emmanuel Macron qui
est une erreur historique à cause
c'était de ne pas prendre son bâton de
pèlerin ou son téléphone de nos jours de
voir chacun des responsables LR et de
leur dire de leur donner des vraies
raisons de d'accepter cette coalition de
les nommer au gouvernement de changer
profondément la plateforme
gouvernementale puisque les les Français
n'avaient pas donné une majorité absolue
et de faire en sorte que cette nouvelle
donne permett de gouverner la France
nous sommes alors qu'on a encore 3 ans
et demi à faire dans un dans un pays qui
ne peut plus gouverner on ne peut plus
passer de loi c'est une folie avec tous
les périls auquels nous avons à faire
face en interne comme en externe c'est
folie éc a fait le choix de ne pas se
rendre au rencontrre de Saint ù Emmanuel
Macron a réuni les chefs de parti est-ce
que c'est responsable quand on est un
parti de gouvernement de pratiquer laque
de la responsable de quoi on parle on
fait toute une histoire Eric cotti il a
eu raison d'être un peu susceptible
quand même y a un moment il y en a marre
quoi Saint-Denis pour faire quoi mais
pour la première fois c'était un bon
coup parce que le début on était à la
fin des vacances voir un peu tout le
monde se mettre autour de la table pour
essayer de trouver des solutions super
voilà très bien discuter
oui d'accord enfin tout le monde sait
que ça marche pas comme ça les
référendums d'abord franchement moi je
me méfie toujours des référendum on les
perd tout le temps enfin passons si on
veut vraiment en faire un on fait du
bilatéral on parle avec vous vous nêtes
pas pour un référendum sur l'immigration
non mais moi je suis de manière générale
extrêmement réservé sur les référendums
parce que bah parce que en fait on gagne
jamais parlez-moi de référendum qui ont
été gagnés depuis depuis 25 ans les gens
ils sont énervés il considèrent que
quand ils ont élu des gens des des
responsables politiques c'est pour
qu'ils fassent pourquoi ils ont été élus
pas pour recommencer à faire d'autres
choses bon donc tout ça c'est bien
gentil mais tant que vous n'avez pas de
majorité à l'Assemblée au Sénat vous ne
pouvez pas travailler c'est ça le vrai
sujet alors moi je veux bien qu'on fasse
une table rondde avec l'extrême gauche
mais ça sert à rien en fait c'est pas là
que ça se passe dernière question Christ
l'attitude aujourd'hui des LR est-ce que
c'est vous l'analyz comme une manière de
préparer la campagne de Laurent vquier
pour 2027 c'est un peu message qu'il
leur a envoyé quand il est allé les voir
à
l'Assemblée alors là je enfin c'est non
je j'avais pas fait le lien je veux dire
l'état de LR aujourd'hui estant ce qu'il
est honnêtement on n est pas là du
Toutin comment vous dire j'ai fait un
petit calcul pas très longs je crois
qu'on a six candidats à la présidence de
la République dans le camp de ce qu'on
appelle piquement l'arc républicain
voyez six euh donc vous avez Édouard
Philippe vous avez Bruno Le Maire vous
avez peut-être gerérald Manin vous avez
Xavier Bertrand vous avezavier berand
vous avez David Lisnard et vous avez
Laurent B sont 6 bon d'ailleurs ceux qui
sont LR sont plutôt dans le bas du
tableau niveau sondage j'ai vu le
dernier sondage où il a leur enoqué à 6
% c'est chaud quand même bon donc avec
tout ça à plus d'un candidat et demi on
n'est pas au deuxième tour quand même he
parce qu'il y a deux tours à la
présidentielle et que vous avez pendant
ce tempslà les deux bloc extrême droite
extrême gauche très organisés qui auront
eux un candidat ça veut dire qu'il faut
trouver un accord entre majorité si on
pense à LR qu'on va réussir tout seul en
envoyant qui vous voulez d'ailleurs moi
je gêne pas c'est une vaste blague avec
ce qu'on a vécu en 2022 moi je propose
quand même qu'on se pose d'autres
questions un peu plus rés candidat
commun à la majorité ah ben je moi à
plus d'un candidat et demi on n'est pas
au deième tour voilà donc c'est vous
pouvez faire tout ce que vous voulez
hein donc moi je les entends tous dire
moi j'irai je suis déterminé oui mais tu
es déterminé tu es à 6 % quand même
c'est génial mais mais tu tu sais faut
faut oui mais ça va s'arranger je crois
pas au sondage super et ben on y va on
continue de perdre voilà merci
jean-fançois coupé merci d'avoir été
avec nous chistal la Une de La Dépêche
les agriculteurs des jeunes agriculteurs
en colère à Toulouse c'est à la Une de
votre journal merci beaucoup on passe au
club des territoires